c'est une ginette reno en grande forme
qui a reçu la légion d'honneur le jour
de ses 76 ans j'aurais aimé que mes
parents soient toujours vivants
pour partager avec humour n'aiguise
unités mais aussi mains jouées
cette récompense pour une carrière de
plus de 60 ans lui a remise six mois
après de graves ennuis de santé où elle
a failli mourir nous et par trois fois
je sais pas le fond
je me rappelle je suis chez moi puis je
vais tomber juste ans puis là je fais tu
veux je veux vraiment mener me chercher
tout de suite je me sens que j'ai encore
d'autres choses à faire l'avancé et pour
me chercher tout de suite et je me suis
accroché à peine gagner
[Musique]
et
et ce sont des admirateurs outre
atlantique qui ont milité pour qu'elle
obtienne la légion d'honneur c'est
gratifiant j'adore le trophy j'adore le
médaille j'adore les prix je le prends
avec des fois je me sens un peu mal à
l'aise mais je les prends avec tout ce
que je peux comme quand j'étais petit
j'aimais sur l'essentiel
c'est d'être aimé en france on l'a déjà
surnommé l' edith piaf québécoise déjà
très populaire dans l'hexagone elle
aurait peut-être pu l'être encore
davantage confie-t-elle je ne sais pas
au début ça a commencé très fort c'était
mais je sais pas des fois je me pose la
question si je me suis pas saboter moi
même cet entraînement
et non sortir gens pendant qu'on la
célèbre ginette reno a une pensée pour
son ami guy lafleur décédé la semaine
dernière j'ai un trouble et j'en ai pour
une fois encore je suis là c'est pour
facile parce qu'on dit notre côté
saint maurice richard sainct ginette
reno ce second se situe vraiment fait
je suis
autres séances d'aquagym et de tai chi
ginette reno écrit son autobiographie et
d'ici la fin d'année elle pourrait
lancer un disque de chansons originales
et remonter sur scène ah non j'ai
vraiment je vigne comme suit la dernière
foire se donner un temps ça donne envie
de chanter c'est celle là où tu vas
chanter je peux ranger comme solo
je ne faisais que le feu
c'est ici oui philippe ouimet radio
canada montréal
[Musique]